Well,
about two years ago,
I stumbled on a piece of neuroscience
that just stunned me,
uh,
as a psychologist,
I wish somebody had told me more about
this,
but um,
what I learned is that there appears to
be a part of our brain called the
ventral striatum.
That's the technical term,
or you also could call it the seeking
system.
And this system is urging us to explore
the boundaries of what we know.
It's urging us to be curious.
And by the way,
I mean innately,
I mean children's six months old,
three months old,
if you give them some toy,
they love it for a little while is they
get used to it.
Your car keys become more interesting.
It's the new and it's the desire to
learn.
And evolutionarily this system was
developed to help us to keep us
learning.
And so when I learned about this seeking
system,
it really turned me on because it
started to give me an insight into why
disengagement from boring work.
That may not be a bug.
That might be a feature on the 2015,
2016 Gallup polls.
The evidence is that about 70 percent of
people are not engaged in what they do
all day long and about 18 percent of
people aren't repulsed.
The actively disengaged from what they
do and I think that the reason why I say
this is a problem and it could even be
called an epidemic is because work is
mostly what we do.
You know,
we spend so much more time at work than
with our families and then those things
called hobbies and so I think that the
pervasiveness of people feeling like
workers,
a thing that we have to shut off from a
thing that we can't be our best selves,
a thing that we have to get through on
the way to the weekend.
I think that that is a sort of
humanistic sickness and while it is bad
for people,
that's the humanistic bit.
It also is really bad for organizations
who get lackluster performance.
I think that it's interesting to think
about when this all started happening
and you know I didn't live back in the
18 fifties,
but all the records suggest that you
could buy shoes and those shoes would be
sold by some store,
some cobbler,
and maybe there'll be three people that
work there.
Rarely would there be five people that
work there and while that probably
wasn't the best work in the world,
each of the people in the store would
watch the customer walk in and then
they'd make a shoe for that customer and
they take leather and they'd sew it and
then they give it in around $18 90.
We got this different idea as a species
where we should not sell two pairs of
shoes each day,
but 2 million and this idea of scaling
up has certain implications for how work
felt and part of that was because it was
decided that the way to do this but have
extreme efficiency by breaking the work
and a really small tasks were most of
the people don't meet the customer.
Most of the people don't invent the
shoe.
Most of the people don't.
Actually see the shoe made from
beginning to end and this idea of
removing the meaning from the work
wasn't intentional and the idea of
removing the curiosity from the job was
intentional.
For Henry Ford.
A curiosity was a bug that was a problem
and you needed to stamp it out in the
name of reliability and quality.
Now I'm not saying we're still acting
just like the 19 hundreds,
but I am saying that that's when we cut
our teeth on management practices and
the way we use control systems and
punishments and extrinsic rewards to
kind of call people out into doing
really repeated and sometimes tedious
tasks again and again and again without
having a sense of the bigger picture or
who uses the final product.
I think that that's part of where it
came from.
So a small organization in any industry
selling toner cartridges,
selling fruit,
selling shoes.
If you're just starting up and you've
only got 30 or 50 people working there,
everybody is curious.
Everybody's doing everything.
There aren't really tight role
descriptions.
The job titles are not burned into your
flesh.
The frame of your job is not sacred and
so you could be a delivery person,
but then if you see the competitors or
do something,
then you can be corporate espionage and
you can take back information and then
you can get into strategy and help
reinvent a response to what you saw and
that's actually not only acceptable,
it's desirable.
The CEO loves you for doing this.
When you get to have 50,000 people in an
organization,
you're supposed to stay in your lane.
You know,
the expectation is there are a set of
Kpis,
key performance indices,
and this is the way that we measure you
on your job and yeah,
it might be that you have ideas about
competitive advantage and what the
competitors are doing,
but there's no time for that because we
need you to do these things that we've
already set aside for you.
Again,
so I think it's in my own opinion,
a lot less about which industry and a
lot more about the culture and the
expectations for what different
employees can bring to the party.